mark zuckerberg aurait-il changé d'avis
il y encore quelques mois le fondateur
de facebook critiquer la décision de
twitter d'étiqueter comme fausse de
publication de donald trump
je ne pense pas que facebook ou les
plateformes internet en général
devraient être les arbitres de la vérité
mais à quelques semaines de l'élection
présidentielle américaine la maîtrise de
l'information devient cruciale et une
fois de plus les réseaux sociaux en sont
le principal champ de bataille
dernière polémique en date le refus de
facebook et twitter d'autoriser le
partage une information du new york post
le célèbre journal conservateur vient de
publier un article sur les liens
présumés entre hunter maiden le fils du
candidat à la présidence joe biden est
un groupe gazier ukrainien selon
l'article
joe biden alors vice-président de barack
obama aurait aidé le groupe gazier but
risma à échapper à des enquêtes
anticorruption qui aurait éclaboussé son
fils qui siégeait à l'époque de 2014 à
2019 au conseil de surveillance de la
société ukrainienne
suite au refus de twitter et facebook de
partager ses informations le locataire
de la maison blanche s'est empressé de
réagir
c'est si affreux que twitter et facebook
et retirer l'article sur les courriels
accablant lie à joe biden l'endormi et
son fils hunter dans le new york post
les plateformes
elle assure avoir agi par inquiétude
quant à la provenance et à la qualité
des informations nous ne voulons pas
encourager le piratage en autorisant la
diffusion de documents obtenus
illégalement
cette histoire est éligible au fact
checking par les partenaires tierces de
facebook
en attendant les vérifications réalisées
par des médias ou des associations
partenaires de facebook dans la lutte
contre les infos que la visibilité de
l'article du new york post en question
sera réduite sur la plateforme
le new york post l'un des quotidiens les
plus lus dans le pays fait pourtant
valoir qu'il a bien spécifié la source
de ces informations
à savoir des emails retrouver sur un
ordinateur portable est laissé dans un
magasin de réparation informatique le
contenu de l'ordinateur a depuis été
saisi par le fbi
dans un éditorial le quotidien
conservateur fustige le parti pris et la
censure de facebook pour aider la
campagne de joe biden censuré d'abord
poser des questions après c'est une
attitude scandaleuse pour l'une des
plateformes les plus puissantes aux
états unis facebook est devenu une
machine de propagande et il est vrai
qu'on est en droit de se poser la
question de la neutralité de ces réseaux
sociaux dans cet épisode
rappelons que toute cette histoire a
commencé avec le tweet d' angie stone
directeur de communication de la
politique de facebook qui ne fait pas
mystère dans sa biographie sur twitter
ne ses amitiés démocrate au terme d'une
journée de polémique le co fondateur de
twitter a finalement reconnu une
communication
ouvrez les guillemets pas génial notre
communication sur nos actions concernant
l'article du new york post n'a pas été
géniale et bloqué le partage de
l'adresse internet de l'article avec
zéro contexte expliquons pourquoi
inacceptable
le new york post elle dénonce un deux
poids deux mesures twitter et facebook
n'ont rien fait pour restreindre l'accès
à la récente histoire du new york times
sur les impôts du président trump cet
article du times up basée là aussi sur
des documents obtenus illégalement
accusait le président américain donne
avoir payé que 750 dollars d'impôts
fédéraux en 2016 et 2017
l'information n'avait pourtant fait
l'objet d'aucune mesure de restriction
particulière sur facebook ni twitter
alors censure partisane excès de zèle ou
neutralité bienveillante
on vous laisse en juger